most of you will be stunning failures
I'm getting kind of this place in my
life where if you can man just do it you
know I want to be competitive I want to
live in the in the world where people
are creating bigger and better shows
need motivation
watch it top 10 with the leave nation
what's up believe nation it's Evan this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a man who went from being a kid so
obsessed with music that his parents
took him to see a psychiatrist twice -
dropping out of college to pursue his
music career
- becoming one of the most well-known
musicians of our time he's John Mayer
and here's my take on his top ten rules
of success
okay let's kick it up with rule number
one define your expectations
number one the thing you have to do
before you set out on any other goal or
any other course is to define your
expectations number one thing on the
outset of every single project record
tour define your expectations everyone
in this room wants to make it but I
question how you would recognize making
it what is making it well what do you
want to be who you in here wants a
record deal would it be nice to
everybody nice that a record deal right
we're gonna record deal okay well what
does a record deal look like now what is
making it look like would you want to
sell a million copies two million copies
well okay let's say selling two million
copies is like selling town 10 million
copies 10 years ago so let's say you say
to yourself my expectation is that I
want to be an artist and I wanted to put
records out and I want to sell millions
of copies if that's your expectation
great then you sort of skip straight to
another questionnaire you know okay if
you answered yes to do I want to be a
pop star do I want to make music for as
many people as possible now you have to
sort of change your game to fit the
expectation you now have to wonder about
is your song shorter than four minutes
do you get to your core as fast enough
these are these are the things you have
to absolutely do and you also have to
compromise and you also have to play the
game and by defining your expectations
if you decide that you want to be a pop
star that's not a dirty word it just
means pop just means popular Frank
Sinatra was a pop star Jimi Hendrix was
a pop star lots of people would pop
stars what kind of pop star lots people
with jazz musicians what kind of jazz
musician can be you can define the genre
any way you want
so if you said you want to be a pop star
then you have to look at your songs
there's also people here who are a
little dishonest about what they really
want to be and I think if you want to be
famous if you want to make music for as
many people as possible just come out
and say it
don't say I want to be indeed
I'm just gonna be an independent artist
and really secretly wish that you wanted
to be a pop star because from the from
them from the very beginning it's
disingenuous there's nothing wrong with
saying I want to play music for as many
people as possible without compromising
the things that I have to be as an
artist and that's what I've done so many
music doesn't come into the studio when
I'm making a record but I also know
what's going to be a hit or what stands
the chance of being a hit and what just
doesn't and it's a level of honesty with
yourself that you have to have before
you hand your music out to anybody else
so that's sort of what I want to say
about expectations if you only recognise
success as a record deal and a big fat
Publishers Clearing House oversized
Tiger Woods check and a dinner and then
going to the top of the roof and
screaming I made it most of you will be
stunning failures rule number two
stay true to your instincts I stayed
pretty true to whatever my instincts are
as an artist sometimes for worse at
first because I think when you do
something that's out of the norm you
have to keep doing it for a little while
to make it your own norm so it's an
exciting idea to me that I could be
putting a record out and being able to
be my own person to not have to think
about what I can't say or can't do
because I don't want to lose people's
understanding of what I do as a
convention you know so I'm really
excited about the idea people going oh
no that's him that's him rule number
three just do it I think that I've got
to make a record that is the ultimate
sort of Here I am you know so I think
it's time to go back and you know it's
like in the movies where the the
ex-marine grows the long beard and long
hair and takes off to like Tibet or
something and then there's always a
moment I don't do that anymore and then
he shows up at the Pentagon and totally
clean shave and he's like where do we
start
I may be shaving the beard soon I'm
getting kind of this place in my life
where if if you can man just do it you
know I went I had this moment where and
my youth I was really frenetic and
everything was like butter and then I
hit this mode where it was like less is
more and now as I get into my later 30s
I'm like if you can do it do it all the
time you know you do it all the time as
long as you can do it do have just shred
show people what you can do you know so
it's a sort of this arc also of how
fancy you think you are and find
yourself to be rule number four be
competitive you know I want to be
competitive I want to live in the in the
world where people are creating bigger
and better shows to try to I think
there's a healthy competition involved
in it you know I went and saw Drake show
and I went there you know like a real
real artists say wow and then they go
right because you see something that
Wow's you and as an artist yourself you
go I want a little of that rule number
five keep changing positively you know
people on the message boards and
websites always talk about he's changing
you know I don't think he could expect a
21 year old kid to stay a 21 year old
kid when he's 31 so yeah the answer is
yup change a lot you know enough predict
I will continue to change you know but
that's not a that's not a dirty word and
that's not a dirty idea as long as that
change is reflected positively and being
on stage and playing and continuing the
story rule number six pick yourself up I
think I'm right in saying that was
sometimes when you've considered
quitting music is that true yeah yeah
I've always thought there was one time
in particular yeah and I'm sort of going
on studying design or something's always
been a passion of yours yeah I like I
really love design yeah actually I just
finished making continuum handed it in
and my manager played it for the head of
the label and I was what'd he say what
do you say what do you say and the call
I remember was the call came in
he said he doesn't hear anything on it
he doesn't hear a hit Watts wants you to
go back and write some more stuff and I
was just like how can you not hear how
special this record is and I just
thought if I can't do that if I can't do
this I'm done you know and the record
went on to be really really successful
and my most successful record to date I
think and it taught me a big lesson
which is like listen to someone's record
twice before yeah you give a point of
view on it so now if anyone ever plays
me a song I go play it again
people a lot of times this assume what
it is they must be saying to you and so
but that that day I thought I'm just
gonna go to Parsons and and I love
design and I love where it's heading and
I want to have something to do with it
and I'm still amateur at it but and how
long did that feeling sort of
disillusionment well that specific
feeling disillusionment lasts for a
couple days IKr but then but then you
think yeah a couple days then you pick
yourself up off the floor but like I
didn't say like I'm gonna quit music and
you didn't smoke crack I said I must
quit music and go to school which I
would have promptly dropped out of to
start my own design company because I
have to do those kind of things
I can't actually follow the curriculum
rule number seven work on your thing
everything you learn is just raw
information what you should start doing
is seeing yourself as a separate being
from anyone else in this room you each
and every one of you now I want to go
home and put it incorporate it after
your name in your head you are now a
being and incorporate we're incorporated
you are now going to take information
and go oh I could use that for this and
that and that don't show your cards to
anybody else some guy comes along these
sounds like thinks he sounds better
maybe you do maybe you don't
but work on your thing and then you can
figure out what makes you you
artistically and then you can
information when I go into the studio
when I sit in with an artist I'm
accessing information I'm not access
it's like a library I know I'm going to
take this out and this sort of like
being a DJ this this will work this will
work but not by way of just playing
everything and that's what I wish people
could do more I don't know if you can do
a real-time I don't know maybe this is
just the time you get everything and you
worry about sort of figuring it out
later but I think it'd be an interesting
idea to look at the information learn it
and then immediately start figuring out
how you use it or how you don't use it
you know a drummer is over playing
guitar players over play singers what
we're saying and songwriters over right
so it's a matter of how you begin to
shape anybody have a jam and they Jam
too much and they run out of ideas and
they get that itchy feeling on the way
home like I just gave up too much like
they just somehow sort of empty I played
everything and I saw the end of my only
musical existence and from the dirty
I was just ended up in there in the
rough the golf core that's that is just
a misappropriation of what you know
you've just all the sudden got to the
bottom of the trick bag and there was a
hole in it you just don't know why do we
chat we jammed on E for an hour rule
number eight do things your way
I know because she told me so I want to
be modern day and I want to play by
modern day rules and excite people but I
also want to do it the way I would do it
everything I've ever picked up that was
was a technology in some way or another
I've always found I think my own voice
with it and so I'm doing the big the big
bad LED show but in a way that tells a
story about me rule number nine
compromise I have a certain gene in my
body that allows me to understand what
someone else is saying when they say we
want to sell a lot of these things like
I don't see selling a bunch of something
as the opposite of it being interesting
or important or meaningful
I've always had I've always seen it from
both sides you know and it's a really
interesting place that I'm in right now
like I you do have to balance you know
if you saw my iTunes playlist I could I
could I don't have a conversation with
anybody at Stereogum or pitchfork you
know but what I do with Columbia Records
as the artist that I am with the records
that I make under the contract
that I have I'm taking all of my
influences and I'm trying to convert
them into pop music that's my job right
now it's not the only thing I can do and
it's not the only thing I will do but as
long as I'm still trying to make pop
songs I want to play by pop rules you
know III want to listen to top 20 and
figure out what's going on I don't want
to fall behind I'm trying to take all
the elements of music that I love that
I'm well-versed in and convert them into
music that a lot of people can get into
I don't know why I do that it's a lot of
people can't a lot of people find the
compromise maddening I see it as another
challenge and I see it as another talent
you know like the ultimate talent of
restraint and rule number 10 the last
one before a very special bonus rule is
the public is always smarter than you
who in here thinks that the public is
mostly done you think the public is
mostly done let me tell you something
the public is about 300 million times
smarter than you public is not done for
those of you said yes I want to be a pop
star yes I would like to have a record
deal yes I'd like to make this happen
first thing you should know is that the
public is always smarter than you if you
put a song out you go that's it that's
it watch it go like whew stand back
everybody stand back it's gonna be a hit
it's gonna
it's gonna be a hit and it goes like
this who is smarter than who your big
smart pop song went nowhere the public
just told you they're smarter than you
on that way cuz you said you had it and
they said I don't think so I think it
didn't have it so they're smarter than
you that's what you have to deal with
they're smarter here's where the public
is smarter than you I wanted a song
called come back to bed
I thought it was going to be huge I
thought it could change people's minds
about stuff no I'm gonna make you like
stuff you don't like because it's good
enough hey I don't know about that and
the song didn't work and I was
disheartened and then they said what
about daughters keep her daughters out
now I had thought again public smarter
they made my thought but that's just
this little song that lives on the
record that's like track eight it's
track nine it's come when you discover
three months saying like oh this is here
and they said no they've researched it
they really want this to go I think it
can be a hit and I was like I don't want
it to be ahead I would rather not have a
hit with this song because this song is
going to take me forever as sensitive
song right
and I gave myself sort of a three
strikes in your out room when I thought
daughters would have been somewhat of
the third strike the worst thing I could
have ever thought it was being the
artist where they go
the record company says look you give us
the three we want and you know we want
and you can do whatever you want to do
I'm sure there's some songs on
Nickelback records at Nickelback love's
somewhere in the back there nine ten
eleven oh you got an Imagine got imagine
there's there's ones on the setlist when
they get up to it they're like I can't
wait to play this one thank God I was
able to write those other three that I
know they needed and I don't mind making
but okay you know so I say please I get
on the phone with Don Eider at the time
was I think sort of just the head of
Allmusic and I said Tommy I can't do it
Tommy you realize if I do this I'm gonna
be sensitive singer/songwriter guy for
the rest of my life and I'm too young
I'm too young to be anything but a guy
who can put out whatever he wants is it
fine fine you know I get it I get it we
won't put it out if you don't want to
moving it out and it made it out I don't
know how it leads but how upset can I be
because of one song of the year that
year for four daughters now I've got a
really special bonus clip from John and
how to bring on vulnerability that I
think you're gonna really enjoy but
before that is time for the three point
landing questions time to move from just
watch another video to actually taking
some kind of action so here we go
brushy number one what are your
instincts telling you to do right now
number two how can you get started and
just do it and number three what will
you do to pick yourself up if you lose
the first time out
is it hard to be vulnerable asks Whitney
Porter it was hard to be vulnerable
because ah the matter inside of me had
yet to sort of figure itself out so me
being vulnerable unleashed a lot of
random stuff it's really fine being
vulnerable now because I Know Who I am
and so I have no problem telling the
truth because the truth is Who I am and
I wouldn't mistake my telling truth now
with being bold or a reverent in the
past so it's really fun to speak the
truth then you can watch people try and
make it two-dimensional and reduce it
and try to turn it into a different
shape and you still look at it and go in
whatever you know so I don't have a
problem being vulnerable it's kind of my
job as a musician and if you know where
you stand
then vulnerability is not scary
vulnerability is scary if you're not
sure where you stand because you're not
sure what the next you know you make
bold statements but you're not sure if
they're you I haven't made a bold
statement in a long time that wasn't
exactly who I am so bring on the
vulnerability raise your standard Apple
at the core is core values is that that
people with passion and
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me
if you guys like this video and want to
learn how to make it as a musician I
highly recommend checking out the video
right next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there I want to tell you
the most important piece of information
that applies not only to your musical
career